our next guest is proof that you can
make a difference
at any age because 11 year old zach
hartman
has made it his mission to give back to
those in need by finding
new homes for used books and stuffed
animals
and in just three years he's collected
over
68 000 items across the country
zach was interviewed by our tampa
station wfla
news on channel 8 earlier this month we
caught the story
and he's here today now with us with his
mom kim
welcome to the show
hello hi guys
wow you both look so fantastic and your
backdrop is amazing
you guys are a vision this is awesome
thank you this is so exciting well
gosh you must be so proud kim
absolutely you know i mean zach's 11 now
but he started this project
uh three and a half years ago and he
just started it literally
to make a difference in our household i
wasn't recycling correctly
and he reprimanded me and grounded me
and then decided to even take it a step
further
and for him to have grown it now to the
size that it is it's
it's kind of unbelievable well zach
you'll be happy to know that when my
daughters and i are both
like when they're working on something
you know like a little something happen
at school and
you know we're dealing with that i make
a list of things i can improve on too
and i think it's amazing
when parents and kids actually can teach
each other and learn together because
we're all growing even though we're
grown-ups we're still growing forever
but what what started this for you what
gave you the idea
so zach's plan is a project i started
when i was seven years old taking out
the trash
taking out the trash was my chore so one
day i decided to look in the trash to
see what we're throwing away
so i opened up the trash lid and i
looked in there
and i saw all this stuff that was
supposed to be recycled so
about five minutes later there was so
much trash scattered around the driveway
and i just wanted to help with that so
i started my project and that's where i
am today
so i collected and donated over 65 000
books
giving them to its schools and little
free libraries across the nation
i've also upcycled 3 000 new stuffed
animals and given them
to animal shelters and humane societies
i
love that detail about donating to the
animal society because
there's a lot of things like when my
kids and i we would donate everything
that we weren't using but there were so
many things like bottles and things and
blankets they were like we can't use
those there's a lot of
protocol and and rules uh for best
practices and sanitation and
protection of everybody but then you're
like but i want to give this somewhere
so the fact that you figured out
to donate the stuffed animals to
shelters is so clever
yep absolutely we found an organization
called glad dogs nation that
he was able to partner with so what they
do is they sanitize the
donation so we get the donations of
stuffed animals they sanitize them
remove the beads for the eyes
and then they put a little um opening in
it he inserts a squeaker he sews them
back up
and then i think he's shipped now
probably to about 20 different states
humane societies and animal shelters
zach um
can i like ever introduce my daughters
to you maybe we could like i'm not
kidding by the way
zoom or facetime i would love them to be
influenced by you you are
so amazing and i know that you have a
gofundme
and uh i saw that you needed like an
extra 1900
to reach your goal um so if it's okay
we want to give you that money and just
kick it right to that goal line today
and it's it's our pleasure and you know
what i
i'm just gonna do five thousand let's
just go five
thank thousand oh my gosh thank you
honestly you are such you are a teacher
you
are inspiring and i'm not kidding i'm
getting us all kim is that okay can we
have like a family
meeting because i really want my
daughters to hear this story and they're
not here today they're in school
that would be amazing that would be so
fun okay perfect then i'll see you guys
soon thank you so much for joining us
[Applause]
today
[Music]
you